Donald Trump has pushed civil asset forfeiture,
which he supports, back in the news.
"We've got a state senator in Texas"
"He was was talking about introducing"
"legislation to require conviction before"
"we can receive the forfeiture money."
"Want to give his name?"
"I'll destroy his career."
Here are 3 reasons why civil asset
forfeiture laws need to be reformed now.
Civil asset forfeiture allows cops and
federal agencies, such as the FBI, to
seize cash and property of suspected criminals.
But it doesn't require them to
bring any charges against their targets
or even show that they were in any way
involved with wrongdoing.
In 2014 for instance
a Philadelphia couple had
their house seized after police arrested
their son for possessing $40
of heroin while living there.
The parents weren't charged with any crime
but in Pennsylvania and many other states
owners have seized property must
prove their innocence to get their stuff back.
In many cases, the agency that seizes
property and cash gets to keep a big
chunk of it to fund purchases of
equipment and pay personnel costs.
In Mississippi, in 2015, state narcotics officers
alone seized 4 million dollars
in cash, cars, and even couches.
In the Magnolia state, cops only get to keep
80 percent of the value of seized assets
but in 26 States law enforcement
gets to keep 100 percent of their haul
giving them an incentive to
grab as much as possible
especially since it's time-consuming and expensive
for defendants to go to court.
Although most states do their best to
hide how much civil forfeiture goes on
it's an increasingly unpopular practice
because it's so obviously contravenes
basic notions of justice.
Even in deep-red states, polls routinely show massive
majorities in favor of reform
once voters understand just how unfair and
non-transparent the process is.
In fact when President Trump threatened to
destroy the career of a Texas state senator
he could have been referring to
any of 4 politicians—
3 Republicans and a Democrat
who were deeply involved
in reform efforts.
Civil asset forfeiture reform is an idea
whose time has come
in Texas and elsewhere
whether Donald Trump is ready
or not.